opponent is probably petrified
uh okay let's play this move thanks for
the sub gifts
atheists so i'm i'm two out of two it's
not a bad start
let's continue with dirty openings okay
four nights
four nights with a3 let's play a
halloween
reverse halloween
it's not a great opening but it's a
scary opening
oh to play here knight g6
i assume this move in this move
i have this move too
i should i should know what to do here
um and d3 is actually
kind of annoying
opponent
yeah um let's play queen f6
idea bishop here maybe bishop c5
[Music]
i'm down the piece i have to prove
something nice dirty win
thank you i'm just realizing my
opponent's raiding
this is probably not the best opening
choice
[Music]
yeah thanks mathias and thank you
double the pawns
okay this is a weak square maybe
something to work with
yeah so it takes i have knight d3
i mean expecting knight d4
knight d4 bishop g4 bishop b2 i have
this move
not sure if if it does anything but it's
interesting
and the great thing about this opening
kind of ooh
never mind just losing another pawn
this is bad too because my bishop's
still hanging
yeah i take all of that back i mean
let's just
still try and fight
still a small time advantage if queen
takes maybe this move
a queen of four or queen f4 i win
what's going on here
the queen has to move back
and then maybe takes and this and this
it's still a fight actually
yeah because my pieces are developed and
white pieces are undeveloped
okay this pawn is weak my g4 ideas
oh there's queen f5 ah the queen f5 i
still have some
compensation okay opponent doesn't play
it
which is good h3 seems very slow
any tricks looking for tricks probably
king b8
queen g5 takes takes liking b8 first
and do my best to avoid trades some idea
of this
i feel like if i want to win this i have
to resort again to dirty flagging
it's not the best feeling
i play bishop e4
there should be four it takes
i mean what else to do
if i take
play this move i can take your
[Music]
attacking the pawn the pawn's playing
very well
okay wait i'm oh i'm attacking the
knight which is basically pinned
if knight moves i take and then take on
f3 wow neil gifting subs
welcome back neil thanks so much
opponents again perplexed
[Music]
probably dazzled by all those sub gifts
let's take and take
okay rook t8 maybe even takes here
okay this is looking pretty good now i
think
i just have to stay calm and focused
have this move
let's move and then this move with queen
check i
check back discovery
i have this move rook takes a3
it doesn't quite work
play this move
let's go three out of three let's go
wow what a game hey tomcats thanks for
subbing
and thanks again neil man i'm so
nerve wracking i won with the reverse
halloween a little bit dirty
towards the end but that's life
yeah some people are doing really well
this tournament
i think it's brian i'm gonna stick with
my stafford gambit rapper tour
is it splits might as well try and be
aggressive
we have a four knights
g3 okay let's
reverse halloween again it worked to
that previous game right
and actually the benefit with g3 is
there's no knight g3 here
i think if knight c3 i play this and
then this i do this and then this
it's been a while since i've looked at
this
[Music]
yeah it's just a matter of throwing
pawns and and trying to make the
opponent scared
uh yeah bishop c4
i think this is a move i remember doing
like very deep prep in this line
it's bishop f7 though bishop 17 d7
still theory maybe
and bishop f7 i think e7 followed by h6
i might just be losing somehow but
i probably have to go for this
i forget where the king moves though
h6r is queen e2 king f6
don't make me please don't make me
i mean this looks like complete garbage
which it kind of is
but
that's probably a good move the rookie
one's coming
remember do you remember the crap itself
no i know the prep
exists somewhere
in the past
to use your king it's like using your
head
to attack
okay so h6 you just want to kick the
knight away and then win the bishop
enjoy life wow h4
that's a nifty move
this move
h4 is a very good move i could take and
get a few pieces
um
this is looking very grim
i think i'll go for this
so i'll have oh i'll have three pieces
oh this is not so bad for some reason i
thought i was only having two pieces
i have three pieces for the queen
huh
my counting abilities can be improved
c7 is attacked d4 also attacked
so look let's still play g5 and just
attack
it's an interesting game so far
and probably i don't know if i'm worse
here it's queen in two pawns for three
miners
23 i have f4 maybe
g5 on the horizon
i mean this looks fun two bishops
[Music]
a fascinating fascinating game so far
wow d4 so opponent wants to fork me
to play this move
so the idea is after never mind
[Music]
i think i can take rook h6 ideas coming
and the bishops are so good together
they keep each other company they
control like all the squares
let's take this rook ga coming
wow
so i can do this
if takes i take takes and then this and
this
i assume this works she allows me to
queen and then
it's a beautiful position where i'm
threatening mate and the rook
and that f4 is defended
yeah so white's just losing it's an
incredible game
wow actually i'm just winning the queen
here
the king can't really move away
what a game that's a nice game
i swear i had some kind of prep though
wait analysis was my prep
i vividly remember studying this
position
king d7 is a draw a king e7 is a way to
play for a win
uh oh king f6 is better for black
but how a great this is a very
interesting game
so deserve a sip of tea oh thanks i'll
take my sip
yeah so this is apparently winning for
black even though i felt like i was
losing during the game
i don't know why bishop e7 so strong
oh bishop e7 just preventing
me from getting skewered and then i'm
winning one of these things
it's an incredible game or incredible uh
opening preparation
because this line at first looks like
black should just
be crushed so i hope people are inspired